all the things we know of properties of
the cancer cell can be traced to the
malfunction of genes that in turn has
raised the possibility of very very
precise therapeutics because if you can
identify the malfunctioning genes in any
individual tumor you can in principle
devise a therapeutic that specifically
targets that malfunction and we call
this targeted therapy actually the very
first example was in breast cancer many
years ago when it was discovered that
the estrogen receptor the molecule that
the hormone estrogen binds to and that
leads to the effect of estrogen on
breast tissue that if you inhibited that
you would have a favorable effect on
many breast cancers and it turned out
that these breast cancers works
expressing the estrogen receptor those
that didn't express this in a receptor
did not respond to the to the
therapeutic so that's a 30 year old
version of targeted therapy
flash-forward to our current knowledge
about the malfunctioning genes of cancer
cells
the next triumph was with a relatively
rare disease known as chronic myeloid
leukemia this was an inevitably fatal
disease the standard chemotherapeutics
had marginal utility with the disease
and we knew that there was a particular
malfunctioning gene in those leukemia
cells and working with a drug company
young medical scientist named Brian
Drucker demonstrated that an existing
therapeutic that was on the Shelf not
being used
was effective against that
malfunctioning gene that was common to
all chronic myeloid leukemia and the
very first tests of that therapeutic
with patients with chronic myeloid
leukemia had what I would call a Lazarus
effect
I mean patients were on their deathbed
and literally stood up within days of
getting as therapeutic and walked out of
the hospital it was astonishing and we
have other examples now so it's what we
need is a complete catalogue of those
genetic malfunctions in various kinds of
cancer that are common enough to create
therapeutics that can then be ready to
go for any individual patient we need
the ability for every hospital to test
every individual tumor for all the
genetic malformations malfunctions for
which we have therapeutics and we're
rapidly approaching that capability
you